hi i'd like to talk about the joe
cytosensei said the 13
joe carter as we know it
was actually a 13 partner practice
and it had the different moves in it
and the moves should be i should have
the feeling of
suburi in them not as the 31
joe carter has that was a carter
and yes it's a partner practice but not
in the same sense
the the 13 is designed so that you have
one attacking
with skis and the other one defending
with
a suburi feeling
so he him saying that uh it was the
missing
suburbs from the 20 joe carter
we should put the feeling and the
understanding together
a lot of people don't know this and they
just do the 13
carter in in a way of a flowing form
you have to determine whether this the
form
is one thing and the carter is another
so when you're doing the carter you just
get a quick
blip it's a little bit like
and that little blip is at the end of
each one so if i was to do
the opening chokazuki
the the taking up the loading
the ski and then all sudden boom
that last piece that last
piece is where all your power is
concentrated
and that's the okay
the aim of these skis are alter this
area of the stone
and it might sound a whole thing to say
because i'm sure that i could over
a good kind of people but the sudden
is third stop the person's electricity
running their heart so
you this is the only intention that
you're doing
it's not just a good bang to the chest
the thud should be so powerful like
perhaps in karate or
tai chi chuan kung fu you know this
strike
that they do everyone does in the
martial arts to the
chest is to throw the heart off its
access
these detailed films
are designed for me to give you the
secrets
of aikido it's not a joke it's not
funny there are secrets and the masters
hand them down
to people like myself who stayed with
them
over many many years they
they get to trust them it's more than
just oh
he's turned up on a seminar he's paid
for his seminar i'll just teach him
stuff
we learn a lot more off than that than
we usually do
on the mat so
why is this only on my patreon
site is because you're
obviously dedicated enough to want to
know the fine
details only a few
will make it most people
drop out like a dough they're not
designed for aikido because
they won't put the commitment in
it's a joyous ride but it's also a
painful
ride and hard work
i will be putting an open youtube video
out
on this but
it's the importance of why you're doing
it
so this is the saburi i stand
i do my standard chocolate
but at the end i have to have a superior
punch to it
i now have to do the block
you'll notice that my body and joe
are the same my feet and my joe
are at the same angle if the camera can
show this
when i take it back down
this end doesn't just drop
down it comes down
and skis or in this
case in the 13 joe carter it
turns and strikes
so we must study the carter not as a
whole
but in sections so that you understand
why you're doing it chocolatizuki
that last part i concentrate my power
you relax the moment you stop the punch
this block i hate
mustn't make you feel like you're
sitting on a bathtub or you've stopped
it's just a block and the feeling is
the body is grounded with the earth
the arms go to heaven so you've got
a strong base
pushing all this to the heavens
a lot of people i'll do it at an
angle a lot of people do this very
incorrect
but i've shown you in other um films
what
not to do so here
punch the block they do this
now you will see from the camera angle
this joe
is a lot smaller than the width of my
head
scentsy used to get really angry with
people
even if they do this it still isn't the
width of my head
you've got to cover the length between
my two
hands must cover my head here
okay so this must be covered
hence you he
he would say it's like the roof of your
house
if you don't have it fully covering your
house water will come in
this is a big big mistake i get quite
angry when people don't do this right
it's not a dance
it's not edge knee you see
my head is sticking out it can be hit
it's a block to stop your head being hit
comfortably it's also
if somebody skis to the lower half
to take the ski and to
throw it away this thing they come up
and you do
you you block it away from you
over the head is to stop it as it comes
down
from a strike so one is to stop
the strike the other one is as they come
with their ski
you brush it by wiping it
this way so you've got two in one there
you've got a block where you
knock it up
and you've got a a wipe
from a ski don't
come back and sit back okay so you know
that
from this point you turn
but don't collapse you turn it in the
position it is bringing your hands
together
you then reach right up to the very end
and this is good if you do yoga because
you have to learn how to
reach don't bring it to you just because
it's comfortable reach
right up you can see it and then
cut
so this is now the opposite side with
the same
things it's either a wipe
from a ski block from a ski thrust
sorry or if somebody's doing a strike
changing strike
it's a block and again
you'll notice it's covering my head
you'll see
on all the youtube phil videos and that
people they think that they know the
carter they weren't trained by
psychosensi he would have never allowed
it
they've seen some films they've had
perhaps bought his books they think
they've got the answers
a master only gives the answers to his
nearest students
there's not many around the world who
hold the five scrolls
okay he uh awarded mine in 1994 the
final ones
because i was in iwana
took my fourth down i took my fifth day
in tai chi
through my fourth down buki waza and he
said tony
i want you to take your fifth the
hamburger rosa because i'm happy with
you
with you
after 19 nearly 20 years of following
him
twice a year for all those years
buying these books costing thousands and
thousands of pounds folding around the
world
he gave me secrets these secrets i'm
trying to pass on to you
if you're in a hurry to think that
there's some magic
bullet magic wand there is no magic wand
but i can save you the rigorous pain
and taking hours and years
of doing incorrect things like picking
the joe up wrong
not knowing about the impact in the last
you know last few centimeters
not covering the head properly
you think it's just a block you don't
realize that there's two in one
a wiping of a joe's ski
or a blocking for chamonix
a turning without collapsing or reaching
up
and striking okay
let's have a look at front door space
reaching up reaching up it takes a lot
of stretch to reach up but don't weaken
just to bring it to your comfort you
a martial artist must push their self
to go beyond comfort
okay we will do more of this
there'll be some outside and we'll cover
the 13
partner practice or if you want to call
it the 13
joe carter and that's fine but
just remember this is
suburi feelings within
the 13 and they're the missing
parts of perhaps what's taught in the 22
suburi thank you for your time
donald